Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
come in dr. Sloane
yes I'm sorry to disturb you sir but
it's urgent
what's wrong there's a sick man in
drawing-room B and his wife's half out
of her mind I wonder if you take a look
at him sir what does he complain of I
don't know sir but he sure sounds bad
and I'd appreciate it if you'd all right
I'll be with you in a minute you are a
medical doctor sir fraid so
there are times when I wish I were a
veterinarian well doctor what is it
you'll be all right can I go to him now
yes maybe you better stay with him I'll
be right back and give him something to
relieve the pain it's a serious doctor
symptoms point to polio polio
unless we work fast we may be in for a
lot of complications what what can we do
we must get him to a hospital as soon as
possible what's the next stop a phoenix
sir 4:00 a.m. three and a half hours so
far too late no I can't take that much
of a chance well sir I don't wait a
minute we go through Winston don't we
yes sir when in about an hour but we
don't stop there well we will denied
there's a hospital in Winston small but
well-equipped all right now here's what
has to be done notify the engineer and
then wire ahead to the stationmaster of
Winston to have an ambulance meet the
Train we've got to work fast above all
stay calm keep this to ourselves is it
contagious sir yes this car will have to
be quarantined until I get him off at
Winston and then you must seal up the
compartment no one need know anything
what cars are ahead of this a baggage
curb well that simplifies things Porter
I want you to stay in the car behind
this and make absolutely sure that no
one enters or leaves this one is that
clear yes sir get on it right away
we're getting close to desert Junction I
better get that wire ready for the
dispatcher there's one more thing I'm
going to need a hypodermic and some
drugs from my suitcase it's been checked
through you'll have to let me under the
baggage car first of course follow me
thank you hi Belle what's up
this is dr. Sloane a passenger took six
seven he needs some medicine from his
suitcase okay
this gym is a doctor ready yeah there's
a guy sticking back get the Ducks bag
and make it snappy
you got a baggage check oh yes there it
is just got that off yeah you'll be all
right
yeah what's wrong with him I'm not sure
sometimes they eat too much when they
train rolls at night how are ya lady
okay okay I was right up here please
take it easy there's glass in that okay
yes thank you that's fine
yeah would you need that put up your
hands please unbuckle your gumbo
Robin
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll move over the door lay on the floor
based on hurry up put your hands behind
your back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what the chat easy and he's got a County
Clerk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm trying to do to smother me I thought
would help you ski I took today yeah me
too you don't have to whisper
I always whisper in the dot the time to
get up
no it's too early go back to bed o sleep
on the plane
you're illegals dénouement I this time
tomorrow we'll be in Mexico City Mexico
City I know you feel hard I'll be
wonderful Mexico City taxco Pueblo Sachi
Sachi Sachi milk oh okay oh you
pronounced it better than I do
please II such a milk girl that's where
the streets are paved with flowers yeah
they used boats for taxis hmm you know
that Mexican song we brought home
yesterday I can't get it out of my mind
salud Felicia detimore means health
happiness and love if he got those and
money and island I look right he hasn't
got him yep but not the right
proportions we lack in money I'll make
up in the love Department
hello Norman speaking what in 15 minutes
but and Riggs Hendricks to be over in 15
minutes
why would that I don't know but it's not
a social call what didn't you tell you
no I didn't say he must have told you
something he didn't tell me anything
well no when he gets here so until they
reach Phoenix at 4:00 a.m. I didn't even
know anything was wrong they couldn't
get in the baggage car they had a bust
their way in
so more coffee mr. Hendricks other
things don't matter if I do that's when
they found him unconscious saved blown
wide open how much they get Sam
everything but the silver I half a
million five hundred thousand dollars in
small notes
well I guess that about covers it let's
get out the air for it wait a minute
you've ruined my vacation at least let
me finish my coffee I'm sorry about this
we did count on this vacation Charlie's
been tired lately and edgy I know I know
I've said all your plans but this calls
for table handling what about Jackson
not enough experience Athiya Jerry Klein
Rogers the phony accident claims a
routine investigation yes but for this I
guess I meant I look Charlie this is our
biggest policy around a limb for half a
million you retrieve it and maybe the
company will buy you a Mexican holiday
who's coming for the railroad Joe I'm
strong he's going on ahead of Phoenix
it's a friend of yours isn't here's they
have Sunday dinner with us every once
while we run out to the same fires good
and your work as a team come on come on
we're late I'll be right with you
baby I'm sorry I blew up at you I know
how much the vacation meant to you - me
too
okay only postpone we'll get there
Shirley take care I'll check it still a
detail can't you remember anything
what's your write down you can see what
you see you can remember
are you tally okay I'm sleepy you'll
wake up yeah I see the company half a
million bucks I get a week and Mexico on
the house but you're lucky all I get is
Paulie from a badge has Ruth she's okay
Oh charlie hello bait your baby yep
how do you like to look at it it is how
we taught it neat job yeah technique and
precision for real pro when we were open
like a penny balloon liquid nitro no
what did they use shaped-charge yeah
that's 101 shape charge the stuff the
Army's been fooling around with that's
it how's it work well in simple terms
it's an explosive molded into the shape
of a cone so that the force of the
explosion is directed like a blowtorch
Oh
in other words they just blew up that
Hindes in the lughead but had they set
it up well either an electric battery or
a detonator we found pieces of wire
what's this muffler probably it's just a
bed pad we'll know more when we get it
down to the lab uh-huh yeah that's
really fun them dead to the world
well Reggie or the witnesses you want to
question them now or sure where I any
other car okay Charlie let's go
Paul I knew you was the doctor on
account of the tar gram well I I guess
he just looked like anybody you know
kind of average it was just like sting
all of a sudden here we had a baggage
check I I found a suitcase right away
yes sir I'm positive she was a blonde a
blonde that tells us a lot
anything nothing no prints nothing
Brenda Bedford had never been washed by
those in any store wires just wires dime
store stuff everything wiped clean they
don't seem to overlook the thing he's
gotta be something to always hit sure
you know where to look for it
Winston let's check on that ambulance
the ambulance men were playing cards you
know just killing time
about 12:30 these two guys come in armed
they were fast and quiet up with your
hands and turned to the wall then they
kong's him on the head PT's then bill
out to get some cold lemonade with you
right yeah like a well rehearsed troupe
of actors they thought of everything no
chance of a slip-up the wire came they
had the ambulance and they were ready
wasn't that a long shot can the
stationmaster at all direct to the
hospital for an ambulance wouldn't made
any difference Joe I checked there is
none other ambulance within 65 miles of
here
yeah someone masterminded this pretty
carefully they cases town inside or not
maybe you can get a lead that way well I
doubt it the too many tourists in
Winston this time of the year they all
ask questions a couple more nosing
around wouldn't cause much of a stir how
about the missing ambulance not so much
as a nibble so far every department in
the state's looking for it
roadblocks posses even got a healer
copter from Phoenix they wouldn't get
very far with an ambulance on the main
highway that's right they couldn't never
to attract too much attention so I told
him I said they wouldn't go far in that
ambulance
they'd ditch it and ditch it close but
it's not far from town it'll show up get
better there's not much else we can do
until it does sure is what we can eat CJ
so long
what's the matter with you never I guess
an easy kid we haven't even started [ __ ]
then and this whole four hours and
haven't figured an escape hatch yet
there's something to occupy your mind
listen to this
Porter delivers wire to compartment B
9:50 p.m. woman calls conductor 12:30
a.m.
why are dispatched to Winstone 12:55
a.m. in Winston 12:30 a.m. pendulums men
knock dead sometime between 12:30 a.m.
and 1:30 robbery occurs train pulls into
Winston 1:40 ambulance waiting 1:50 a.m.
ambulance drives off token train pulls
out yeah reads like a freight
dispatchers timetable everything in
place no loose ends no leads so far
sounds like the beginning of a perfect
crime must have been something to watch
save your admiration charlie I've been a
cop for a long time I've seen some good
jobs and their jobs but I've never seen
a perfect one that's always a first time
jihad oh there's no such thing as a
perfect crime just a lucky one but their
luck will run out what's not gonna run
out tonight I think I'll write the hotel
and call Ruth's total gonna be stuck
here for a while okay
make that windows right he was in a
minute we toasted two coffees to me
Bobby no when did taking the ambulance
reports they came here and a Highway
Patrol helicopter spotted 220 miles out
of time
I told you the first break maybe that
Luck's beginning to run out taste the
coffee let's get out there brother
good night's sleep can do
look Java wasting time well maybe they
slipped they've been too careful let's
forget about the ambulance to find out
where they went
I've been trying to find out it's not
worthy with his father me as how one
thing's for sure they didn't drive well
how do you know the ground it's too dry
dry as powder no other tracks just the
ambulance but how maybe there's your
answer Joe
we got the copter over in the field
[Music]
anything
blood and plenty of it see what I'm
eating Charlie that Luck's beginning to
run out
why is it so much hotter here in
Riverside than LA what do you make it
the blood don't know nobody was hurt the
robbery maybe somebody was too pretty
it could have been an accident maybe it
doesn't matter either way
what do you mean by that it's only
important who was hurt or helped the
important thing is it was known that I'm
Tim and that's what's going to trap them
Charlie everything was too well timed
no leeway and if they went on schedule
once just once Joe huh oh it's you what
the CIA report the copter blonde with
guy named al wolf he runs a charter
service in Burbank later I doubt it
what you reported missing four weeks ago
oh well let's go have a talk with him
anyway you may get Sully yeah free ride
around the airport
hey Mack
[Music]
wolf around yeah he's around are you
getting forest yeah sure hey wolfy yeah
hi how many planes can I sell you guys
we're checking on the guy who charted
your copter about four weeks ago oh yeah
well it's like I told the CIA the guy
looked perfectly all right he had a
license of legit reason and cash lots of
cash yeah I was I supposed to know he's
a phony you know times ain't so good
right now
hundred bucks a day jobs don't come
along every day in the week the reason
he gave you what was it please said it
was flying up to Nevada something to do
with uranium you're just gonna look over
a claim I think you said then you
believed it look buddy I talked she had
a lot of cash paid me for six days
he could have said he was going to the
moon remember what he look like
sure he's a nice-looking guy very
pleasant personality that already can
remember well he was a big guy and like
I said a very pleasant personality
Buddha thought he was a phony thank you
very much mr. Wolfe we'll be in touch
with you
mm Oh what about my captain sorry but
we'll have to hang on to it for a while
been impounded as evidence but get it
back to you as soon as possible look I
need it now I can rent it to a movie
company they're making a flying picture
I've time to make a Western are you sure
you don't want to lie down for a while
honey
you look beat but the are already told
you I've got work to do I if I lie down
at piles I'm getting buried under it
but it can wait for an hour can't it oh
darling you shouldn't drive yourself
like this it isn't worth it you've just
got to relax gotta relax I'm here of
your forehead let me get you slippers
Shruti what do you know about this why
don't you just leave me alone
you must have fly off like that all
right someone fly off you won't make
anything happen sooner by beating
yourself you know what Joe says you've
just got to have patience yeah I know
what your says and patience is fine for
a guy like George goes with his to pants
suit is washable necktie and it's 49 car
for me patience is poison charlie could
I help
what could you do you've never tested me
Charlie
let's not begin now hello everything a
half hour I'm sorry buddy I gotta go
Charlie what happened which one his own
getting in a plane before the getaway
was timed
Charlie was an accident accident now we
don't want any more accidents Odie
carrying a gun for all he had to do was
play sick and lie on a stretcher he had
an idea I had a timetable for months I
studied the east and the west bound
trains I wrote the coaches like a candy
butcher I memorized the baggage car I
studied the crew movements the
compartment layout I rehearsed every
move with you and Paul over and over and
over what could we do we have to stay
with Lombard we couldn't just let him
die you would have wanted that would you
would you Charlie
no of course not
how bad is he not good let me have it
straight for lumber I pulled through
well Paul keeps taking care of him now
yes he's doing everything he can to look
good dr. Charlie as good as when I
married he has got a drink in four days
they better not where are they in
Chatsworth wolf took us to a place yes
you're full of surprises aren't you most
part of the job was over he landed that
helicopter I told Paul to pay everyone
up and split up had it gone somewhere so
what steps into the picture
what doesn't know about you he's still
things Paul planned I still don't like
it now the wolf knows we all run a risk
what else could we do why did you switch
the schedule you were supposed to be in
Mexico City what are you doing here
you're the mastermind here every minute
ticked off for each of us you followed
your own timetable you'd have been there
trying to get a shut up oh why didn't
you leave why did you kill him you are
in my control and all I could you mean
you wouldn't you
all across - didn't you I'm on the case
lender the company assigned me to
recover the money I could roll with that
one
I thought you were in Mexico City but
when I called the hotel from Winston you
weren't there either I nearly went out
of my mind I didn't want it gone wrong
all I know is I had to get the back to
LA I've had to leave the mayor by the
hand we found the plane but
[Music]
and then he went crazy host about which
one it could have been yours right
nothing to be frightened of but I know I
can have are you sure they're telling to
be frightened aren't you ever afraid why
should I be my job is to catch myself
from here on I control everything I know
what they're looking for I can stop them
from finding it just takes more time
that's what going our schedule means
more time till they run themselves
ragged and give up what about Paul maybe
he won't wanna wait doesn't matter what
he wants he'll do what I tell him he has
the money tell him I want to see him
tomorrow here with the money here all
right Linda there's nothing to be
frightened now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I love you learned
[Music]
[Music]
take your time I had to be careful
I wasn't sure this was a place and I
heard the music clipping Linda's
favorite song health happiness the money
so we're lucky yeah very nice your dough
belongs to a friend of mine
what about Lombard how is he dead you're
a friend isn't an enemy of alcohol isn't
Dumbo I didn't have a chance I did
everything I could
Charlie short of transfusions Wonder
drugs and prayer I was a very good
surgeon you know and - what about that
drink huh
what you do with the body
Wolf's getting our Dylan not worthy
Charlie he knows what he's doing a very
good amateur Undertaker very expensive
too that was a funeral that wouldn't
wait he wanted lombard sheriff her doing
the job did you give it to him
sure why not what's $15,000 is plenty of
go Ron what about the Evans boys paid
them off - oh yes first night
no country why not just as we planned
you did a great job Paul the only lead
was the copter I planned on that I'm
strong swallow bull story hole Armstrong
railroads prize Cobb were a team I
remember told me about that has great
possibilities for a man with iron nerve
if he knew who you really are
he's followed you for a cop they'll be
too amused I'll be head and tail on the
same coin the veins changing our plans
our plans I hardly see Charlie how your
personal complications affect me I was
in this for one thing the money now I've
got it and I intend to enjoy just how
you think you're doing that going to
Mexico just like you plan we won't go
together that's all how far do you think
you'd get you're a fool Paul for sure no
no I meant I know what you meant
don't even think of it we lost our
chance for a quick getaway lombards
bundling fix that it's too late now you
understand I could make it Charlie I
know I could without anybody to give you
orders be a cop every two feet you
couldn't slip a bag of popcorn past
enough they'd pick you up in five
minutes what are we going to do Charlie
what you want us to do hole up and wait
we got all the time in the world
when can we go when I tell you how I
tell you Paul you're great you're just
great as long as you're following orders
but the next time you get an original
idea remember when we first ran into
each other you were trying to beat the
company with a claim that any
ten-year-old kid could have seen through
yes I remember Charley you pulled me out
of that hole I suppose you can pull us
out of this one what's next
get clear of Wolf's place and we'll move
into a motel don't spend more than one
night keep moving south
check with me every day let me know
where you are and wait well good start
don't you want a cot it I trust you Paul
sure you do we trust each other
[Music]
I'll have to tell Linda to be more
careful with their lipsticks or will you
tell and she said that she talked to you
on the phone oh by the way Charlie you
would have liked her blonde very
exciting manager you run out of
notebooks but you can see you can
remember my old man taught me this trick
Oh was he a football coach no just a
cracker barrel philosopher sheriff of
Haines burg Missouri well he was on a
case they write everything down on the
blackboard never solve anything that way
never missed one he'd sit in front of it
for hours studying the cold Frank's one
they'd sunk in it erase them I need
start thinking about people it's okay if
you know who you're thinking about but
this isn't a case of who stole Farmer
bronze cow or see doctor for nothing's
turned up on any still no medical
surprise no illegal drug sales anyway
that guy knew what he was doing when he
came to giving a hypo just a possibility
that's all
other doctors in the country jail you
ever know you're planning on checking
all of them ever have to what happens
when you get to the end of that line
what about all the retired medics and
those that have been barred from
practice look we'll be checking a lot of
things within the next few weeks most of
it won't mean much but every now and
then something they join what it does
will write it down keep your eye on that
blackboard shall we
while we erase the facts we've got our
case I get a rosy
[Music]
Norman speaking station yeah what for
okay
mr. gravelly Jim thanks let's try it
again Frankie
I'll give me a break will you I drove a
car that's all I didn't have anything to
do with the robbery I didn't even know
there was a robbery till I read in the
papers
stop taking long shots Frankie y'all not
ran out he's here okay
it's true you've gotta believe me
some guy came up to me what guy I don't
know his name just a guy said he see me
hanging around la looking for hungry
buck one didn't know if I'd like to make
some quick dough and you said sure what
else could I say hey I was down to
eating bees all he wanted me to do is
send a wire to some character on the
train and then grab a car onto a field
and Riverside
it's all a perfectly honest job I
thought it was legitimate when you say
it for you huh dollar an hour what did
he pay $5,000
it's quite a day's pay then one I did it
I was ill that fear when he told me to
be couldn't knock me over when I copped
it came in they tell you what they've
been up to no honest they are honest no
see nobody said anything all the way in
the San Berdoo
nobody said nothing only this guy
moaning and bleeding nobody said
anything it gave me the creeps
come on Frankie that's a long drive I
just told you nobody said nothing it was
just this guy in blood was it Frankie
what did you get remember well was this
Dame Z what about the Dame well this
guy's Mullen must have gotten on her
nerves cuz she said a couple of things
to one of the guys shut her up
what'd she say I don't know see it's not
a kind of flower like nom breeze or Nam
was Nam something number today deals
how's that sound
yeah that's it anything else you can
remember no nothing I thought I was yeah
I drove the car back the same but do the
guy paid me off he told me to square
obeyed you geesh I don't know it was
dark I couldn't see anything
I hung around samba do a couple of days
and then I got restless yeah I'm always
getting restless moving around
you come in please
ever seen this man before Frankie
recognizing take your time
No
who's that all that's all mr. wolf
thanks for coming down
[Music]
what do you want I just like word with
you you don't mind why don't you guys
leave me alone I don't like people
busted in here cops are no cops I'm not
a cop I'm an insurance investigator
well I don't need any mister
cozy place you've got here
do you mind I'm superstitious you know
if I thought you were gonna kiss my
couch I'd of had soft lights or sweet
music no I just like you to answer cup a
question Oh mister why don't you go back
to your insurance boss and tell him that
you drew a blank I already told you or
not under guy the the top everything I
know I'm fresh out of answers maybe I
maybe aren't what does that mean
Frankie page he seemed to know you but
it turned out he didn't after all you
were there yeah a couple of nights in
jail oh they refresh your memory
alright you got something on your mind
what is it did you kill her Lombard no
when's the last time you saw three years
ago the lion wolf you ever see Frankie
page before no well if you're too sharp
a poker player to run a bluff in a game
like this what's that supposed to mean
Frank your page you may remember he made
talk
it could mean 20 years counting wolf 20
lay off me will you kill Larry Lombard
and bury his body and Chatsworth leave
me alone you're on a ranch in Chatsworth
don't you there's an a crime known real
estate now just so long as you don't use
it as a private cemetery I told you I
don't know nothing not even Paul
Bruckner Oh No
I'm clean wolf you've been tailed since
the first day of this case every move
every phone call everybody you saw why'd
you kill Harry Lombard I didn't kill him
it was an accident his gun went off and
then brought me oh you do know Bruckner
yeah your brother you planned this whole
thing didn't you no oh it was brought me
he just came to me and asked me if I
want to make some dough how do you know
you weren't Simon pure but somebody told
me was to fly wetbacks up from Mexico Oh
told him I don't know maybe his name I
don't know it was a long time ago I I
just thought I was gonna pick up some
wetbacks no Winston I I don't know
nothing about the robbery the day I
wouldn't buy that if you're a blind
ground for 20 years
wait a minute wait a minute okay I I was
in on and I knew what I was doing but
but I didn't plan it it was Bruckner
Bruckner was the brains he set it up
that's who you were protecting sure sure
but no more your leaders to him what's
in it for me wolf is the time to wheel
in the time to deal
this isn't your time okay
they ran out on me him and his wife they
got all the dough I didn't get enough
and a couple of grand nothing you know
where they are now
yeah I know where they uh I was staying
at my place in Chatsworth and they left
sudden so I followed him all right a
motel in Culver City I'll write down the
address for you you're remembering
better all the time
sub dos you don't know that Dame Eve no
blonde go on and Bruckner Bruckner took
a bum rap as a medic this gets better
all the time and you will talk to the DA
why not
it ran out on me didn't they sure I'll
talk I'll tell them everything that's
what I had to find out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
papers are getting us a bad time
have you read this one yeah yeah I read
it over a cold cup of coffee that is
null that's cold
they've got a dead-end case it's too bad
wolf would have broken sooner or later
he broke all right right down the middle
yeah no thanks I never thought he was
the type fact I still don't maybe
what do you mean maybe you saw him it
was copy a tough little guy to never
figure him to do the Dutch maybe wasn't
as tough as we figured yeah wolf had
$65,000 buried in that hangar and I
thought he'd have had one big fling that
shoot himself in a crummy room oh you
never can tell what a conscience will do
to a man and even destroy him oh yeah
and the case I think I'll call
Hendrickson have him take me off the
case a couple of weeks in a Mexico
before the summer's over you might as
well before you're too old across the
border as of now we're nowhere so Ruth
and I need new places new places
well Joe don't say it hasn't been fun
there just just one big party
bring me back some jumping beans I'll do
that hello Armstrong just a minute
charlie yeah yeah okay that was a DA's
office what they have to say from now on
we played my old man's way from here and
we're dealing with people what do you
mean by that
wait that mr. big old out slow
[Music]
he panicked during a routine customs
inspection the Tijuana this morning
tried to drive through the barrier they
shot him and he's dead
is there anyone with him yeah the woman
but she got away
they found $200,000 on him she must have
the resident Shelly looks like he going
to Mexico after all you have another way
I'd planned look why don't you call
Hendricks before we late once we get the
woman you recovered the bulk of the
movie your jobs over so so you and
rifted take off until woman not a bad
idea
see your type and meet me down there
Saturday even if we don't pick up the
woman right away it'll give you an
rooster chance to brush up on your
Spanish okay and that's not counting the
money what money you'd save on plane
tickets no tax in Mexico
you'd save 60 bucks oh sure I forgot
about that every little bit helps jolly
good idea I think I'll call Hendricks
you probably go for it all right you do
that and go home and pack a clean shirt
I'll pick you up in a couple of hours
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you should have let me packed I could
have kept all the creases on the right
places you have enough to do anything
special you want me to bring down like
your fishing gear I won't be doing any
fishing Ruthie well you can if you want
to I don't have plenty to do oh by the
way there's a dispatch case in the back
of the car some stuff in the office just
throw it in with the rest of the bags
really from the office yeah some annual
reports I promised Hendrix I'd finish
them up in Mexico noise take me there so
well he's got his nerve and the
important thing is he's letting us go
sorry you're getting stuck with the
packing no I don't mind
it'll be fine now that we're really
going you just throw everything in the
car I'll meet you at the border on
Saturday well it's Jill if I everything
charlie
how'd you better kiss me sure
here here and here the road south of
Rosarito Beach the road to Ducati
they're all covered
we have hopes you won't have any problem
he's got 200,000 downloads owner and
she's a blonde the money may help she
could shorter the wrong person but I'm
not sure about the blonde she was shot
before done he was still dark but when
the woman run away one of the inspectors
got a look at her she couldn't tell much
but he was sure she was not a blonde all
of our witnesses said blonde they saw in
the lighted corridor not on the dark
street what's he could he used I tell
Desmond her hair was brown he didn't see
she had brown hair senior Norman can
really say she wasn't wrong Oh what
difference does it make we still don't
know what she looks like all we know is
that she's a woman blonde brown red or
green hair just a woman true which is a
woman on the run there's no place she
could go without attracting some
attention
I'm for a shower - thinks think about -
I don't I'd stop by the airport and
check on those tickets okay I'll see you
later might even buy you a beer fest
wouldn't she can standard Sudhir's girl
let me drop you by the hotel nah don't
bother the town's full of kids
hey don't slice up lieutenant Castro's
car
[Music]
[Music]
can he see the
[Music]
[Music]
yes Enya
where's Bobby I'll wait
suit yourself drink is it alright
is it a rifling delete should I give it
rank she a big girl give a drink you
heard what he said more so give me
scotch
[Music]
you're nice getting ready to why won't
you drink with me I don't think that
because you're good
[Music]
how particularly you are good a good
little angular with pretty brown eyes
lots of American dollars
where's Bobby didn't you hear the
muffler he's not in dance with me where
is he
dance with me you dance with me I'll
tell you know I with Babak in his office
with bombing in his office
[Music]
oh you
[Music]
what do you want I'm looking for a woman
buttock
[Music]
so pure woman and deer water you must
look for one in my office
[Music]
get out there's a particular kind of a
woman buttock what kind of woman is that
the kind that al wolf would have brought
you the kind that needed help
like Lombard needed help only he doesn't
need it anymore
[Music]
bye bye
114 Calvados Anita dull forties Tijuana
[Music]
about that woman Pollock hard I've known
about you and L will for a long time
playing your high class went back game a
lot of people could use a passport away
over the country I can be cruel Bob
again but it paid it bought whooping
Airport in your club you're crazy
I haven't got much time where's the
woman you're police I wouldn't be
playing around if I were I'll take you
to her first I make a phone call you're
not very bright [ __ ] very well she's
here safe
her husband's are raised with two eyes
and keen passports after the Board of
the asteroid took Herman you still have
the passports yes they're beautiful in a
way out of Mexico also beautiful but it
will cost money
how much $20,000 but it is foolproof hey
I'd send my own mother that way your
problem they have I'll be using those
passports you figure sell I want em
tomorrow night
money add tomorrow night half one you
get us into Buenos Aires
don't argue father I'm not in the mood
[Music]
hello Linda Charlie
[Applause]
[Music]
what I'd loved you you think I wanted to
go poor Charlie threatened to tell the
police money gave my feeling power
dreams of a new life
[Music]
he didn't make what we will endure
everything will be alright
I share the money be handed me tomorrow
in 24 hours we'll be halfway to
Argentine be together
[Music]
[Music]
Charlie yeah I was just going to look
real oh it's hot
wait he just got a call from Cabot
latent prints we've got an ID on Sloane
all that song his real name was Paul
Bruckner lived in San Francisco married
to a Mexican girl named Linda
he was legitimate - but he was kicked
out from my own practice here creeping
up on him
once you've got a man's right name he
quits being a shadow what's the next
step we dig into Bruckner his life in
San Francisco
what tonsils he took out what babies had
delivered how he lost his license
I asked copy Jo me no thanks I'm still
hated enough besides I had to drink your
beer to last night last night
I I wouldn't write in my room Sam better
get going I've gotta meet with the
border what did you do
don't go away that's all right joy nice
Thanks sure are you again but I don't
want to miss seeing his face when she
finally gets to Mexico
hey wait a minute
looks like you're going away for ten
years yes looks like it doesn't
shall we unpack not don't why don't we
be left here dinner whenever you say
Charlie I'm tired very tired Joe why
don't you take a nap for an hour so what
do you'll be doing boy
I liked your buddies annual reports why
I thought you deserved that job for
Mexico City Canada my mine I think I'll
do it now I was going to surprise you
take along your fishing gear put it in
there so I had a key made myoga the case
[Music]
it was to be a surprise a joke something
to laugh about
[Music]
[Music]
what you do with the money I'm there
with mr. Hendrix no return address
crazy poor do you know what you've done
do you
[Music]
why'd you do it why why what does it
matter I killed a man to protect that
money and you'll have to kill me hold
your charlie
[Music]
what do you want from me a few hours
just a few hours
so willing to give you my whole life
what's a few hours
they don't tell me let me touch you let
me talk to you say but there's so much
to say please at least tell me what we
were going to do
we weren't going into anything
[Music]
I was gonna Lydia
I love you Charlie
not enough
once it was
[Music]
what did I fail you didn't fail people
change
[Music]
we had so much Charlie why why our house
becomes prisoner Javad crap what did you
want a new kind of life the kind of
$200,000 coulda bought me alone
[Music]
hello
but you can't have that now
no you fix it
Charlie if you went with me if you said
I did it I'm sorry you're getting the
money back
Charlie oh I'd wait I had the strengths
I have the patience I'd wait no matter
how long there's the title enough in all
eternity Ruth I killed a man you
couldn't wait for me
[Music]
that's the way you want it loan goodbye
[Music]
goodbye Charlie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Shelly wait a minute we got some
more on Bruckner what
lieutenant Castro detected for me a
hunch but he paid off
Bruckner was married here in Tijuana
seven years ago to a singin a club named
Linda Howell Boris when was that club
you know what Kelly Envy
well there were other business did he
sing any place else perhaps it won't
take long to find out a few secrets in
people wanna well I've gotta go I'm
gonna get some things for roads no no
nothing do you have a drink with me well
did you have too much a drink last night
one of my men saw that car parked right
next to babak's last night police cars
attract an awful lot of attention in
that district I stopped for drink on my
way back from the airport it wasn't a
trend you stopped for you probably heard
about the dancer they have there she's
pretty nice huh yeah yes ray I have I
gotta run I'll see you later a very
impatient man Bob H is hardly the place
for a tourist or is your friend trying
to combine business with pleasure maybe
who is it it's Joe Ruth let me come in
oh wait a minute
come in
anything wrong
I don't know of course not why oh I
don't know you and Charlie you both seem
a bit edgy sure everything's all right
I just told you everything is fine why
shouldn't it be
right
I've known you a long time you don't
write very well what do you mean there's
Charlie in any trouble why don't you
stop being a cop you make a case out of
everything you're making one out of this
oh there's no trouble - a few words
between husband and wife
sometimes charlie flies off I just had a
log in them that's all okay how can
anybody argue with you or maybe I'm just
prejudiced no it's better than you
Charlie's been under a lot of stress Joe
or every case is an ulcer but in this
one the way our Charlie's been riding
himself maybe it interfered with his
holiday he promised it to himself and to
me there we go Fiesta
will you kid looks forward to a birthday
party he's just overworked he's been
edgy for months ever since Hendricks
sent him up to San Francisco
well I hadn't read am I expected to on
the plane it's a long trip to Mexico
City yeah long trip
all of six hours enough reading for a
year
operator I want to speak to mr. Sam
Hendricks Victoria anion
for 901 Burbank California that's right
all right away good
hello Hendricks Armstrong
yeah from Tijuana Oh fine fine
well Kendricks Charlie was on a case
several months ago up in San Francisco
can you give me any dope point I'll uh
I'll explain later
a sound wait
you know people on a plane too choosy
they like to read things that are bright
take their mind of the possibility of
crash I'll repeat that a phony accident
claim eight months ago huh yeah
a doctor who dr. Paul Bruckner
thank you
[Music]
take that mind
crash I'm sorry booth
[Music]
[Music]
was all planned I changed my mind
I don't wanna go to Buenos Aires direct
I want to go to Acapulco by boat I'll
pay you more for the passports
how much more five thousand way no
twenty five thousand dollars payable now
you get everything I sports but
certificates everything what about
passage self so y'all freighter Las
Vegas Casa del Norte Rose rate the beach
you tell him public sentiment fishermen
they will understand overly charge what
does it matter a few hundred dollars
maybe five six hundred who knows just
cheap no money if you've got the
passports I'll tell you you tell me
children
[Music]
leave the money product
[Music]
[Music]
this way
[Music]
try we can't make it
[Music]
take that car and block out the other
side of the street now la puente LA
Manzana you see analysis possible
escutcheon
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Charlie Charlie
[Music]
[Music]
Joe
[Music]
this was not the timetable either
[Music]
[Music]